I had major brain surgery when I was 14 years old
for a condition called Chiari malformation.
And they went into the back part of my head,
and they removed two inches of my skull and my first vertebrae
to give my brain more room.
And after that brain surgery,
I was diagnosed with a very long list of conditions,
including POTS, fibromyalgia,
and a condition that has to do with my spinal cord,
with fluid flowing into my spinal cord.
I have personally noticed since being diagnosed with POTS and pepper
my algae,
that in the colder months and when fall comes and winter is here,
I struggle the most. Some of the symptoms are extreme fatigue,
dizziness, half of your extremities being hot,
half of your extremities being cold.
That happens to me a lot. Getting really hot easily.
Getting really cold easily.
My fiber,
my algae also gets a lot worse when I'm not sleeping very well.
And if I don't get at least eight to 10 hours,
my body is, like,
not doing great with it.
What's crazy is that I remember when I had brain surgery,
my neurosurgeon said that I needed to be sleeping 12 hours,
12 hours a night. And after my brain surgery,
I was sleep up to 16 hours a night.
I say all that to say that if you have autoimmune issues
like POTS or fibromyalgia,
I just wanted to share some tips that I have implemented in my life.
That have made a difference.
This is not medical advice,
this is just some things that have helped me.
Starting off strong with No. 1 turmeric.
I take turmeric every day.
You have to be careful with turmeric because if you take too much,
it can be really hard on your gut.
But it has made a world of a difference for me.
I just can't be popping ibuprofen every day
and this has helped lower my inflammation a lot.
The next thing in these colder months is the sauna.
I actually have a at home portable sauna.
And using the sauna three to five times a week
during the colder months makes a huge difference for me.
And my pain and my energy levels
and just the warmth of it all has really made a difference.
And then the last thing that I just wanna say,
and this might sound redundant,
but just eating warm foods and drinking warm drinks.
So I. I am a avid matcha drinker.
I don't drink coffee a lot.
I stay on matcha because of the pots and matches.
A lot more level when it comes to the caffeine levels.
And I just feel a lot more stable with it.
And it has made a huge difference in my life.
And I like to drink it hot in the mornings for fall and winter.
And I also eat a lot of soups and drink a lot of broth.
And those things have helped me
And while these are not cures by any means,
they could potentially help you manage your symptoms.
Again, not medical advice. Just what has helped me